thank you
[Music]
this is Star Talk
Cosmic queries Edition Neil deGrasse
Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist and I got with me co-host
Matt Kirsch and Matt welcome back thank
you so much how's it going all right
dude your host uh probably science and
and you're based out in LA right I am
and I'm briefly back there I've been I
think every time I've recorded with you
recently I've been in a different hotel
room but I this is I don't need to know
your private life why you give me that
much information I didn't did I ask
highest bid I will take wherever you
need me to go just excellent so Matt
this is a cosmic queries Edition on
everybody's favorite subject
base civilizations oh my gosh oh I love
thinking about it but I claim no
particular expertise in it so we cone
the landscape and we found somebody who
was all up in it
all up in space civilizations and
someone that goes by the name of Ariel
ekblau Ariel welcome to StarTalk
thank you so much for having me it is
such a treat to be here excellent
excellent and so I'm looking at your
resume here it's like what what I feel
like a dog hearing a high-pitched
whistle you're CEO of the Aurelia
Institute
okay I'll read some more here and then
you're going to have to do some
explaining here founder and director of
the MIT space exploration initiative
author of into the anthropocosmos
one word there whoa and your research
focuses on a test array platforms which
sounds very acronym so let's see if we
can unpack that tessellated
electromagnetic space structures for the
exploration of reconfigurable adaptive
environments
and you want people to buy that
you terribly tortured acronym never
again but I learned my lesson oh my gosh
you could call it just let's go to space
right so tell me what all this is so
what is the Aurelia Institute what's
your background first what's your
background
yeah so background my parents are both
Pilots I grew up with a real love of
Science Fiction in undergrad I studied
physics math and philosophy I always
really loved big picture questions about
the universe but I decided I want to get
more concrete not just you know studying
physics and cosmology and particle
physics so I transitioned in grad school
to do space exploration and my PhD was
tesserae looking at robotic
self-assembling systems to build
habitats out in orbit that are way
bigger than your biggest rocket pillar
Ferry wow wow so I remember going
decades back because I'm an old fart
here in this conversation that who was
it who's the guy
um Matt you might remember who's the guy
who who had the L5 Society it was the he
was founder of it I think oh I don't
know this is the L5 Society okay okay
excuse me I should just ask Ariel all
right see I'm I'm assuming we would only
know it for having to live through it
but of course she would know who we're
talking about here so the Mr O'Neill
right he was into big space colonies are
you trying to make his vision real 100 I
am a huge Jerry O'Neil fan High Frontier
like his vision for life and space I
think was really compelling we'll do it
a little differently now it's a little
different than how it was consumed up in
the 60s and 70s right because he was
almost cult-like and I'm presumably
you're born well after that man was long
gone but you're now trying to Res that's
why I asked that's why I asked Matt
instead of you because he might have
been alive but you you dug up his ashes
and you're trying you're I'm trying to
reassemble them reassemble the man's
ashes yes because I've seen okay I've
seen artist illustrations of what he was
imagining is that what you're imagining
that is or imagine the secret Keystone
of our system is going to have Jerry
O'Neill's ashes in this stuff I'm joking
okay but no it is very much a source of
inspiration which is large-scale science
fiction worthy space structures how do
you build them and then how do you think
about the society operating and
hopefully thriving not just surviving
inside of them so tell me uh Tesla later
we've all seen that word and we think we
know what it means and I think I know
what it means but you've got it applied
to space here so tell me what's going on
here because when I think of tessellated
I think of a same shape repeated but
maybe but shifted a little bit so that
you can you can build a surface yeah so
tell me more about it tessellating
so the idea of tessera is to take
pentagons and hexagons they tessellate
in 3D and when you have enough of them
they form a buckyball again really
inspired by but Mr Fuller's face of
Earth people have seen geodesic drones
before but it's a particularly efficient
shape for space you want to maximize
your interior volume for a given surface
area so a sphere would be super
efficient what's a little bit more easy
to build than a sphere and is more
modular a buckyball and so the tiles of
the tesserae are pentacons and hexagons
that can pack flat in a rocket basically
think about it like a glorified Pez
dispenser once you're out in orbit those
now we're speaking my language yeah
does it have a little duck head on it
whatever you like pop out the the the
basic uh bricks basically it bricks
exactly the unit of your construction
building we sometimes talk about them
like space Legos if Legos had magnets so
it's meant to be really simple they find
each other the tiles have some
sophisticated code and sensors and
electronics that help them dock the
magnets Supply the docking and if they
do it wrong if the two tiles come
together incorrectly they pick up on
that themselves they have this
intelligence embedded into each building
brick into each unit and then over time
they're able to assemble a large Dome or
a self-assembling habitat you have
intelligent bricks basically
self-assembling pieces here exactly well
to that intelligent why would they
misattach in the first place gotcha
gotcha you got me absolutely let's ask
the tough questions well we don't want
to over constrain them and so there's
some freedom of the magnets to dock in
and out of plane it's important for some
of the flexibility of the system overall
and so then being able to have
self-corrective logic is an important
piece of it the other aspect is the
beauty of a modular habitat is very
different than any other type of space
habitat we have right now if there's a
micrometeorite impact that hits file or
in a happier situation maybe you're
having a conference in space and where
you had a window tile yesterday now you
need a birthing port to be able to
welcome 10 other spaceships to come join
you with a reconfigurable modular
habitat you can pop tiles on and off at
will and so you can have a essentially a
habitat that evolves to your mission
needs ever any period of time oh okay so
it is Legos
I just like it
Spade Lego being smarter than me
angst out there right right yeah
friendly they're very friendly all right
how do you how do how do you deal with
gravity
how do we deal with gravity if you're
rotating what do you have going there
yes so the initial conception is using
microgravity to help themselves right so
they're floating in space and then some
of the work of Aurelia Institute that
you had alluded to earlier is moving
beyond these just kind of you know
passive pressure containing orbs to
actually rotating them to get artificial
gravity so the next series of projects
that we're working on designing are
around the artificial gravity Direction
but the way that we work at Aurelia is
we test out these Concepts in miniature
in space demonstration missions
technology demonstration missions so the
technology behind test array the small
tiles have been tested twice now on the
International Space Station they're
still under development and we're just
beginning to conceive of a similarly
small scale test bed that will help us
learn more about bearings and rotating
large you know pieces of architecture in
space to get artificial gravity but it's
all part of this larger Tech roadmap all
right it's one thing to have the house
now where's the food come from ah the
space food well we're thinking about
what are all of the accoutrement that
need to go inside of that Habitat to
make it a real life worth living where
more people see themselves in that
environment I think a lot of people look
at the International Space Station and
it's very impressive but it looks like a
science lab not everybody wants to live
inside a science lab so the other things
that we had worked on for the last six
years at the MIT lab that's where I
started before we spun out Aurelia
Institute
we were looking at fermented food miso
we flew miso to the International Space
Station we designed musical instruments
that could only play in microgravity so
that we're inventing new cultural
artifacts for life in space looking at
biophilia and how do you surround
yourself with plants that's more than
just a factory farm in space what is
what is it like what is musical
instrument that can only work in
microgravity how does it physically
differ right so there's kind of couple
ways to do it one is that the physical
mechanisms only make sound when they're
floating so when they're passive and
they're on Earth there's just passive
there's not anything happening but they
actually have some agency and as they
begin to float or are tossed between two
human players to musicians in orbit
that's where the sound is generated the
other way to do it is with
accelerometers so nerd nugget a way that
we're actually able to use sensors to
measure the presence or absence of
gravity and acceleration and so you can
also do it with accelerometers and a
essentially a synthesized like digital
music so you can have a whole zero g
orchestra that would be hilarious I love
that you just said that that's exactly
what we have been working up towards is
we have a few instruments and the idea
is to have a zero gravity Orchestra okay
you know what you definitely need though
you need a theremin oh we so need a
therapist doesn't need gravity I think
it's just electromagnetic fields uh you
know theremin Matt I do yeah yeah yeah
friend of mine had one official sound of
aliens in 1950s movies
um I uh
try like I'm aware of the idea of
rotating a spacecraft to generate
artificial gravity has that been tried
in real life has or is this just
something that's theoretical so it's
it's theoretical but it's very practical
so it's not an open science question
that we have to solve it's more like
open engineering Logistics very
important distinction excellent
distinction there right it's not like
well how do we do it no it's just like
rotating right right yeah right yeah got
to build it yeah so we're just working
on small scale uh mock-ups to get us
there and then the idea is to learn
enough about the ways that subsystems
interact that when we actually build the
big one that we've learned enough to
make that a successful project well I
can't believe we made this like a whole
subject for this show which means we
solicited from our patreon members
questions on this tub this subject and
Matt you have them all I haven't seen
them so I do yes yeah see what you can
slip one in before we end the first
segment I can certainly do that uh so
Cameron Bishop says I've seen a lot of
artists impressions of future human
exploration in places like cloaks
proximity to Jupiter or Saturn uh
apparently Neil you've even said you
want to do ice fishing on one of those
moons yeah I want to cut a hole in the
ice and go ice fishing yes get in there
but aren't those planets in their close
orbits in case your shells of very high
energy belts of radiation how are we
going to ensure that future explorers
aren't microwaved like a Hot Pocket
we're visiting the awesome planets in
our solar system
nobody wants to be a Hot Pocket okay
yeah yeah so Aaron what are you doing I
mean not only obviously Jupiter has a
very hostile radiation environment but
even if you're outside of Earth's
protective magnetic
blanket
um how what protections do you have it
doesn't sound like your your triangle
your pentagons and hexagons can do this
could can they
it depends on what materials we choose
so we're modeling some of the structures
for around lure of orbit similar to what
the ISS is so a stuffed Whipple
structure but once we're actually Beyond
low earth orbit beyond the Van Allen
belts there is a much more significant
radiation load and so some of the
proposals I wouldn't take credit for
inventing them we're building on the
shoulders of giants here at Nasa and
others but things like waterfalls or
additional metal shielding
um other types of radiation protection
that can be built into the habitat
infrastructure for a longer generation
water is highly absorbent of high energy
uh radiation so you're thinking maybe
that your sphere your Bucky sphere it
has a layer of water on its outer
surface perhaps and it's a good way to
also get the what we call the
environmental control and life support
system going there's a lot of water that
needs to be recycled in a space habitat
gray water like what you do you know in
a building on earth we do recycle urine
in space and so being able to make use
of those liquids and other contexts
maybe for water walls or radiation
protection is one of the proposals
that's out there so you recycle urine as
well as like body sweat that evaporates
into the air right I mean all of that
it's important it's a closed-loop
ecosystem the best that we can do to
really make it a closed loop recycling
ecosystem scenario if I'm going there
I'm going to last you a comment so I
have fresh water every morning okay
y'all could drink the pee recycle B I'm
gonna have my own tap of keg right after
right out the window I already got my
own my own damn comment
yeah so okay so it's it's an engineering
challenge that does have Solutions
waiting to be invoked but you don't
foresee for example hanging out near
Jupiter anytime soon is that right
probably not in our particular habit
debt not not in the test array but we're
working on different models who knows I
think other interesting points like
Europa uh there are other you know good
justifications for getting out to Europa
for the search for life in the universe
but the habitats that we were just
talking about the testing model is
really meant for Earth's moon and Mars
like the near neighborhood but if we
find life on Europa I think we should
call them Europeans don't you yeah
one more question see if we slip one
more in go
okay so well you've answered the first
half of this about microgravity but uh
Brady Harman says have there been any
developments in artificial gravity is it
all sci-fi or can we do it and also
Brady says vegemite's serving tip of the
day spread on a hard-boiled egg I'm
guessing Brady is from Australia yeah
right it can only be from Australia if
he's given culinary tips for adventure
Mike
uh let's take a quick break and when we
come back with our guest Ariel
we're gonna find out about how do we
make artificial gravity they do it in
sci-fi with or without rotating space
station so let's find out when we return
we're back start talk Cosmic queries
we're talking about space civilizations
and we have an actual authentic
scientifically trained engineeringly
trained person thinking about this not
just crazy sci-fi people who just make
stuff up we have an authentic person
making stuff
Matt where did we leave off we had a
question about so yeah we had we had
Brady from Australia who as well as
Vegemite serving tips wanted to know if
there'd been any recent developments in
artificial gravity yeah other than a
rotating platform Ariel is there any
other way to do this doesn't seem like
there would be that's what we're
focusing on is the rotating platform I
think one interesting tidbit for Brady
so there's a couple different ways to do
it right you can do a smaller ring and
rotate it fast but that's going to be
uncomfortable for the astronauts or the
future space flight participants or you
can do a really big ring and rotate it
slowly but then it's a bigger challenge
to build and to operate and so we're
trying to find that sweet spot the right
size of an artificial gravity station
and a quick fun recent update there's a
group called gravity Labs that's looking
at
um making real a technology that was
described in Hail Mary Andy Weir's
latest book we love Andy Weir he's a
friend we love Andy Weir I know we love
Andy here I also love anywhere
um but that tether approach a very basic
approach to generating artificial
gravity even before you have some
beautiful ring that's like fully encased
uh there's a cool company out there
gravity Labs so it's looking at doing
that for a science lab not necessarily
to put humans in it just yet but to be
able to test out that platform so
there's some kind of gondola at the end
end of a tether that gets swung around
and in that Gondola you'd have the
gravity that you seek I love that you
know the most high-tech science to get
the stuff up there but underneath it
it's no more complex than when you're a
kid and you swing a bucket on a rope
that's right it's fundamental physics it
turns out the laws of physics are
supposed to behave somewhat consistently
throughout the Universe yeah yeah not
only yeah when you're a kid but when
you're in space yeah so yeah all right
cool what else you got Matt well I'm
going to combine these two questions
because that's they're sort of opposite
sides of the same coin so Craig Caldwell
from Bedford UK
says Craig is 33 and do you think it'll
be possible within my lifetime to visit
space in some form of another or for a
reasonable price I know you can go at
the moment for a ridiculous price but I
imagine like most things will become
more affordable for everyday people in
the future and I love the show and then
Andrew O says why should I care about
space tourism it'll likely never be
something I could afford and wouldn't
frequent rocket launches increase CO2
needlessly or for the rich to get a
front row seat to the fruits of their
late of their labor so oh wait wait so
Ariel so tell me about the point
Counterpoint the exhaust of the main
rockets in modern rockets yes so this is
a great question about the environmental
impact that the space industry might
have right now the space industry's
carbon footprint much lower than
Aviation right but if we succeed in our
goals of having way more frequent
launches then there is a significant
potential impact and so there's some
fantastic research already into green
propellants how to try to before we get
as deep into things as the aviation
industry is actually try to solve this
up front I am not a rocket scientist I
am a space habitat engineer and designer
but we are very closely looking at the
carbon footprint in the environmental
impact for this scaling up of life in
space okay and when is it going to be
cheap
okay this is the question the answer to
their question is absolutely in their
lifetimes they will get to go and it
will be more affordable more affordable
than it is now yep so if we're looking
at the next if there's 33 right in the
next 30 years we are at the cusp right
now of a explosion of new technology
maybe it was not the right word to use
bad words
and explosions of anything okay but we
are at this inflection point where the
cost of going to space is coming down
multiple different companies and not
just governments and that's why it's a
big deal there's actually an economy
growing up around this now that's more
sustainable and the cost will be
dropping so it will be older than our 33
year old guy I don't have another 33
years to wait this out so when can you
do it in my lifetime
okay thank you
I feel like I feel like you know some
people who work at some of these
companies Neil I feel like you're near
the you're nearer the top of the guest
list than most of us but
um yeah well related to that as well
Amelia Silva asks what do you think is
the next most important technological
advancement that we need to make in
order to bring down the cost of space
travel duh it's warp drives everyone
knows that next question yeah okay no no
Ariel just really big bottles and really
big pumps where is the biggest cost is
it in the engineering setup is it the
launch cost is it keeping you alive once
you're there it seems to me those those
expenses have been shifting relative to
each other over the decades I think they
really have been right now people would
still say it's Mass to orbit so it's the
launch costs but reusable Rockets like
spacex's reusable platform have actually
been succeeding and really bringing
those costs down so there will be a
point where the costs transition to
maybe what is more driving it is the
length of stay and orbit or the number
of people or this you know the logistics
the supply chain that you're trying to
support once we have a large Human
Society up there so but right now so per
pound what is what is it today per pound
so it varies really wildly
um usually quoted per kilogram it can be
in the thousands like tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands
um per kilogram right now to put a like
a small cubesat into orbit because the
price is a little different depending on
what you're paying to go up okay a small
cubesat about two hundred thousand
dollars okay so I have a middle-aged man
belly so each pound of that man belly is
like tens of thousands of dollars but
now you have to measure it in cubesats
like you have to give me the use of and
then I can give you an accurate book so
I need like ripped abs and no excess fat
and then I get a cheaper ride into space
that's what you're telling me here I
think
but we're we're getting there I think uh
because it's not just SpaceX is the only
game in town now blue origin right there
aiming to get orbital
um Starship Next Generation SpaceX Ula
and others it's a really fantastic
ecosystem that's going to make it
possible for your for your guests to go
in their lifestyle so you haven't
mentioned it until just now but there's
a lot of what you're doing on the backs
of launch companies that are coming
online right now it is absolutely we
need the road to space to be built to be
able to empower this next Generation
life in space so absolutely yeah and we
work really closely with a lot of these
launch companies to get experiments to
orbit right even before we're building
the big habitats all of those other
things we talked about we test the
musical instruments on zero gravity
flights I've flown in zero gravity nine
times over the course of my career to
MIT hundreds of parabolas to test all
this stuff and that yeah it's incredibly
amazing to get to work on the shoulders
of those companies for people that don't
otherwise no so you can experience zero
g without quote going into space to get
on one of these vomit comets I think
they don't want to call it that anymore
affectionately known
and so they can go very high and execute
an arc where that Arc is basically in
free fall back to Earth for how much but
it's only for seconds right how much
time do you get in free fall yeah it's
15 to 20 seconds but it's like a roller
coaster in the sky because you do that
that Arc that you describe that
parabolic arcs 30 to 40 times oh my gosh
okay so that's why I would love that
like my favorite ride in theme parks
rather than the roller coasters I I love
I love the pirate ship
and yeah the the sort of little and you
feel it the zero gravity feeling in your
belly or when you go over a hill quickly
on your little hump in the car
it'll just transition to zero g it's
zero g and then you come out of COG to
more than one G and then so my stomach
will be floating and I know I'm I'm made
of inadequate stuff I don't think I
think you'd love it I think you'd love
it and that's one of the cool things
about the space industry it's actually
some of the work we're doing with
Aurelia Institute is to welcome Everyday
People onto the zero g flight so we have
an application program where you can
come to Aurelia we bring Outreach
partners and the people love it it's I
hate roller coasters but I love the zero
g flight it's actually far smoother and
it's a incredibly Sublime experience to
be truly weightless and imagine your
life in space you're being badass here I
don't roller coasters don't excite me
space exactly put me in space I'm going
roller coaster you're free that's for
regular people you know there's a fun
video of Stephen Hawking on one of the
zero there is flights where he comes out
of his wheelchair and there's a smile if
you've ever seen one on the man's face
not the man's face it's it's a profound
moment it's a really profound right
right right so Matt keep them coming
well this is this feeds very neatly into
this and also overlaps with your parents
profession uh Tarina from San Francisco
says I remember an episode of things you
thought you knew that's one of our
spin-offs from StarTalk yes and in that
you explained why people don't throw up
on planes as often as they used to
how will space tourism manage to help
several nauseated tourists enter orbit
throwing up during every trip sounds
like a tourism Downer especially since
if you throw up in zero g the throw-up
just floats in the air this is true and
it's it's just in the air and it gets in
your hair and it wears on One Tree the
thought you know the the splatter
pattern on the sidewalk outside of bars
at 2 A.M that's the the famous throw-up
pattern because gravity brings it down
all right so Ariel what are you gonna do
with all the tourists throw up
there's fantastic anti-motion sickness
medication uh either Dramamine or
scopalamine um things like that that
Nasa uses as well to help people feel a
little bit comfortable but there's also
a lot of really great research here at
MIT and elsewhere around space sickness
and how to overcome that
um how to train your vestibular system
to behave or to appreciate it a little
bit differently
um but it is
yeah yeah so it's a little bit of that
cognitive dissonance of your body feels
a different gravity Vector than it's
used to but your eyes are still seeing
as stable environment in front of you
and that cognitive dissonance sometimes
in the vestibular inner ear and versus
what your eyes are seeing can make
people look pretty queasy my
understanding that's also behind just
regular travel sickness isn't it that's
why it's easier to look at the Horizon
when you're on a boat because when
you're inside the boat you your eyes are
telling you everything's stable but your
body is telling you no it's not you're
bouncing around and same with reading at
a back of a car as well right
yes yes it's actually so well it's funny
it's not necessarily correlated people
who get okay get Space sick but it is
related some of the yeah some of the
feelings and the sensations that you get
but some astronauts do and some
astronauts don't and it's actually one
of the things that NASA has the most
trouble predicting when they select
astronauts is who is going to get
um you know have a little bit of a tough
time acclimating to just basically I
guarantee I'll get Space sick
you have to wonder about me on that one
so we're going down further down the
list now Neil yeah
no no I got iron stomach now put me in
space right now let's go all right yeah
so because in a zero g bubble any throw
up that escapes whatever vacuum you're
trying to it just stays there like
forever until that's so fun yeah yeah
that's not the only thing that's
interesting about the human body from a
health perspective in space we can get
into this in a minute but if we're
talking about space societies shape of
your eyeballs changes your heart gets
weaker
um you get space space because the
fluids redistribute to your body in a
crazy way so there's all kinds of human
physiology what is space face
so space spaces um because gravity is
usually helping your fluids throughout
your body drain you know drain towards
your toes in space it redistributes and
you get puffy space phase and that's
part of why astronauts are obsessed with
hot sauce because they can't taste
anything it's like having a head cold
the whole time and so the hot sauce and
the Sriracha really cuts through the
space face
bulge or something what happens becomes
slightly more spherical and so any
change to your eyeball shape is also
going to affect your lens and your
eyesight there's bone health challenges
because you're not walking Against
Gravity so your bones weaken this is all
why artificial gravity in a space
habitat is so important because we
really do need to be able to have people
spend time in close to 1G to keep their
bodies healthy okay so Ariel I'm waiting
for 1G I'm not I'm not paying you a
million dollars for my eyeballs to pop
out and my face to explode and my and to
lose taste no no I'm staying here okay
and just so you know can I just ask as
well so is
from a sort of body scientific point of
view if you do have a rotating
spacecraft that generates the equivalent
to 1G will your body experience that
exactly the same as the way someone on
Earth just in regular 1G would
experience it or is it are there
different forces acting on you
interesting so if you're actually able
to spin the habitat adequately in the
super local space where you're walking
in 1G you will experience it much like
you would experience it on Earth but
there's going to be a gradient as you
get close to the center of the Ring
it'll be more and more and more like
microgravity so you want to basically
stay right on the edge of that ring
where you're actually going to be able
to be generating the forces that would
be more like what you would feel on
Earth and I think I've seen some sci-fi
where they have ladders that connect
from the outer ring to the center and as
they move up the ladder they get become
they weigh less and less and right in
the core they they don't weigh anything
so that transition is there right
exactly and to your point earlier Neil
about the L5 society and Jerry O'Neill
this is something he writes about in the
High Frontier that you could have you
could be one of those books yeah yeah
you could be bicycling up a mountain and
then be floating and you have a flying
bicycle as you get up to the the level
of the the port of the habitat that's
not rotating that's not as fast so yes
right right before the the axis of the
rotation right yeah the mountain goes up
there but also there's something
profound here Matt if you didn't know
this that your the 1G you experience
minus this this gradient effect going
towards the center right at the rotating
outer section
is actually
indistinguishably identical to the
gravitational force that would give you
one G and that is the foundation of
Einstein's general theory of relativity
and it's called the equivalence
principle and it's one of the most
profound acts of human thought in the
history of human thought
is to equate those two
forces the force of rotation or
acceleration right like what you'd have
in a rotating object and standing here
on Earth what he said was these are
indistinguishable from each other in in
principle and to build all mathematics
and a whole branch of physics around
that it's crazy crazy this is such a
great Point Neil too because as a space
person I get asked a lot about zero
gravity and that's why we try to be
careful to say microgravity because
there really is no zero gravity right
Newton tells us the law of gravity tells
us so there's always a gravitational
attraction between objects but if you're
in free fall you're feeling like you're
not being act upon by gravity but you
very much are and so that's it yeah like
I just don't like microgram here
you're not getting me to say
microgravity unless I'm saying it to say
that I'm not going to say it I'll take
my wins where I can get them as long as
we'll get you into space Neil um
I'm Max well give me one more before we
go to our next break
Andrew Atkins says do you think that the
future space exploration and tourism
will depend on our ability to develop
some sort of cryogenesis or stasis for
humans or will we work more towards
sending out machine-based AI to do all
the traveling for us love the show oh
because it seems to me Ariel it's a
great question I think Andrew is
thinking are we going to travel to the
stars or something where it would take
decades or maybe even centuries where
we'd have to somehow put ourselves in
suspended animation but all your
destinations you can get there in a few
days right right right it's a great
question because the search for
exoplanets and Goldilocks planets is
raising these questions about if we find
some would we want to go out and travel
to them how would we get to them how
would we do suspended animation but for
our near-term habitats in the area of
the solar system that we're
contemplating we would not need to yeah
put humans on that level of stasis but
we would also in kind of symbiosis with
robots we would work with those probes
and with other tools so I think the
future human exploration is going to be
one where robots do play a really big
role especially with new Evolution of AI
chat GPT there's amazing and I want to
get back to you on that after this break
the what role AI might play in this when
we return start talk Cosmic queries this
is the space civilization Edition when
we return
we're back Star Talk this is a space
civilization edition of cosmic queries
and we've got one of the world's X I say
the world's expert in thinking this
stuff through Ariel ekblaw uh Ariel how
do we find you on are you on social
media you have a footprint there I am on
social media I'm at aerial underscore on
Twitter
um you can also find Our Spell actually
well you can't just say that by and not
spell that for people the usual way Neil
the way you always smell it away
uh e k b as in boy l-a-w aerial
understand Ariel not the way we spell
the in the Disney Princess because
actually the same way yeah it's
a-r-i-e-l underscore
okay that's your uh Twitter personal yep
Twitter and then uh Aurelia
a-u-r-e-l-i-a Aurelia underscore Labs uh
for both Twitter and Instagram
that's a new habitat building lab that's
meant to be the Bell Labs of space and
so you spun that off from your time at
MIT is that correct or did MIT stole an
umbrella to you yeah so I'm still I'm
actually here at MIT today I'm sitting
here at MIT but um we have passed the
Baton for the lab that I founded at MIT
to another amazing person Cody Page
who's going to take that forward and so
I ran that Lab at MIT for seven years
but we'll still continue to support it
because it's my baby so I love it you
birthed it okay but now but you spun off
and now you have like you pay rent on a
different space is that correct yep yep
it's yeah that's I love that you asked
that that's what makes it real it is so
true
what money is paying for this if this is
not going to happen for 30 years yeah so
this is the this is the benefit of being
a non-profit we're not a for-profit and
that was very intentional because I
wanted the freedom to think really long
term for Humanity's Horizons and do a
lot of education and Outreach work like
the zero G5 that we've been for Aurelia
um but it's philanthropic support it's
support from companies and support from
Grants like NASA okay all right very
good very good we got my vote if you
need a vote
thank you well you should come and visit
sometime you know when I talk to all
right next time I'm in Cambridge I'm
totally you're in Cambridge I guess is
that correct I'm in Cambridge yes all
right Cambridge
so so Matt give me some more give me
another question here yes so Christian
Holmes says hello director ekbla are
there any plans for terraforming planets
in the future if not what would be
viable ways for an advanced species to
terraform a planet you know
hypothetically so she doesn't want a
terraformer planet because she wants
everyone to live in her habitat see how
did you know
I bet I know the answer to this question
it's gonna say terraforming that's for
centuries from now okay let's let's
listen Okay Ariel what's your answer to
that question terraforming that's for
centuries about that well yes yes and no
um there's two answers to the
terraforming question one thing I just
want to give a quick plug for Earth
there is no planet where humans have
co-involved in the way that we have
co-evolved on Earth so I think
terraforming is an amazing concept but
it's not going to create a plan B Planet
so when we go out to do space
exploration we should be still really
protecting and preserving Earth honoring
that it's not about abandoning Earth
what do you mean co-evolved co-evolved
with what yeah with the the biosphere
the geology and the geophysics of Earth
this is the place where our human
biology and the biology of the planet
have lived in symbiosis have lived in
together that's what terraform is going
to be will you tell me we can't figure
that out
maybe we can figure it out when will it
evolve if we succeed in it then humans
will continue as a species right natural
selection to evolve with terraforming
but Mars is usually where people talk
about terraforming one of the challenges
is there's no liquid iron core moving in
the center of Mars to produce a magnetic
field like what we have on Earth which
helps protect our atmosphere so if you
are going to terraform Mars you're going
to have to be constantly replenishing
the atmosphere that you're trying to
keep around the planet
um NASA and some others have some fun
ideas for this you could put a basically
a shade at a certain point in space and
block the Cosmic Wind Block some of the
solar radiation that would be coming and
blowing your atmosphere away but that's
one of the big challenges to get
terraforming going and then the final
answer is exactly what Neil said yes
just come live and my floating space
habitat my space my Jerry O'Neill's
Space City it will be better there's no
perchlorates in the soil it's a much
better place I brought oh man okay fresh
soils that's what we want are you going
to have farm animals there too like in
the images I saw of the Jerry O'Neill
space habitats there were these there
was farming communities and it was all
on our sort of rotating inside surface
of a rotating cylinder and so you look
at it there's Farm plots of farm animals
silos uh yeah so so would you I presume
you wouldn't want Supply ships to bring
you food you'd want it to be
self-sustaining that's correct this is
one of those lovely things that has
changed a little bit since the 1960s
it's delightful to look at those Jerry
O'Neil images but they're a little bit
like 1960s Suburbia or rural taken up
into space we have a chance now whether
it's lab grown meat or sophisticated
Urban architecture and agriculture in
resource constraint environments to
design we could design a more urban
landscape within one of those habitats
so there's a lot of choice now in how we
think about the urban planning kind of
at planetary scale or urban planning at
this really massive habitat scale in a
city people are stacked High because
there's not much space but if you're in
space
why would you ever need a city you stack
radiately you stack immediately you grow
in three dimensions in a way you never
could on earth oh okay all right they're
a good answer you know the other cool
thing I just want to sneak in here is to
spin those cities right now for
artificial gravity we're thinking Motors
a lot of energy there is a model where
you could have a city in space that
spins on the power of light alone so you
have solar sails like planetary Society
right and they're able to pick up the
photons that incident energy and spin
your habitat around
right but once it's spinning it'll just
keep spinning right you don't just take
energy energy to start it but you don't
have to take energy to sustain it
presumably energy to sustain it and also
just slow it down to stop it so you do
also have to design in those features to
basically be able to retract the solar
cells if you need that's when people
start throwing up when you start
speeding it up and slowing it down I'm
just I'm still thinking about this
you're reminding me keeping me honest
that's the fun times I'm still thinking
about the throw up all right all right
Matt what else you got so Matthew uh
swider I hope I pronounced that close to
correct says what safeguards are we
putting into place to protect the planet
from space debris with a push for space
tourism I love it because space because
it seems to me Ariel a lot of space
debris might be closer to Earth than
this place you might build your space
station your space habitat so so there's
space debris that we're responsible for
and then there's this meteors that
Earth plows through several hundred meat
tons of meteors a day and that's just
stuff in space so if Earth is doing it
you're going to be doing it too so what
what's your what's your shield for this
I'm the man-made Capri side this is
actually one of the topics that's near
and dear to my heart we put out a book a
few years ago called into the anthropo
cosmos and the idea was how do you be
good stewards of the space Commons and
over the last few decades they really
haven't been there's so much debris like
Neil said between where we are on the
surface and where I want my habitats to
be that we have to pass through now and
to answer the the question from the from
the audience member one of the ways that
we could address the man-made debris
would be to do an approach kind of like
Pac-Man in space a large spacecraft of
some sort goes and physically captures
debris maybe with a net maybe with other
mechanisms
like some kind of space goat yeah
I got this everyone participates in it
so you control your own Pac-Man space
eater right like twitch Twitch Plays
Pokemon but Twitch Plays Pac-Man right
and so you see where a piece of debris
is and you navigate to it and you Chomp
it and it's a contest so you can eat the
most degree boy you clear up space like
that no actually we put crowdsource you
gamify it oh my gosh oh my God yeah all
right let's do it you got it you got it
so that
so you so but you can't stop meteor
showers from slamming into your so what
what do you do about that that's the
harder one so that's where we need micro
meteorite debris Shields and some of the
technology that we developed in the
space exploration initiative back at MIT
one of the students here Juliana turston
an amazing PhD student
um who's looking at building Next
Generation skins of habitats so I'm
working on the shell she's working on
these skins that can pinpoint exactly
where a impact happened maybe detect a
gas leak or detect something from this
impact and then try to be able to
self-heal the habitat
um that works for small stuff as Neil
was saying there's also big stuff that
you just need to be able to navigate
around it and sometimes even the ISS has
to boost its orbit and move out of a
cloud of debris that would be coming
towards it so it's not way better to
have like laser blasters yes
a little bit of Dr Evil face mixer yes
you don't move out of the way of it you
just vaporize
if I remember anything though from 80s
computer games if you blast something it
then splits into two slightly smaller
ones and then you need to blast them and
then eventually
that's true I think no that would be
like a kinetic kill but a laser kill you
would thermally vaporize it and then
it's just dust at that point yeah I had
the wrong weapons in the game gaseous
gaseous dust that that's all so so uh
Ariel tell me about what let's go
revisit just the role of AI in this yes
um how do you see it at its most helpful
and how do you see it where it might be
it's least helpful possibly detrimental
to your goals
well the latter first that would be how
we definitely don't want to how you
don't want homicidal computers in the
pod bay doors hell yeah we're trying to
avoid that version of the AI agent but
something that even just within the last
few weeks chat GPT coming online and
providing this nature of a AI assistant
that is almost as sophisticated as what
we see in Star Trek when they talk to
the computer and it's a fully useful
kind of native language experience we
have that now with chat GPT and so
imagining responsive space habitats of
the future with AI agents Incorporated
will be a really big part of what
Aerospace nerds we like to call human
factors okay you know what scares the
hell out of me what it's
the
capacity for language to be thoroughly
ambiguous true so that to say we have
language models that understand our
language no I don't trust
you know the most famous sentence in
that world is
um
time flies like an arrow
fruit flies like a banana
okay okay
these two sentences are identical in
structure
with similar words and a completely
different meanings and so you disabled
chat GPT would just know and but what
I'm saying is Wars have been fought the
history of civilization over because a
comma was in the wrong place in a
sentence or at least we're told that
happened but I can completely believe it
so I I worry that the absence of
precision of language should not be
mixed with the Precision necessary to
not die in space that's my opinion
that's my that's my public service that
extends I think you're writing that
extends to many different things where
it's there's a a desire to integrate
chat GPT all of a sudden really quickly
but there definitely is a need for a
human in the loop or some type of you
know AI safety control infrastructure as
well which absolutely would be something
for a mission critical context like
space that we I shared on a board of the
Pentagon for several years and AI was
becoming that much more visible over
those years and so we drafted a document
such that if any commander is gonna if
any AI is in the position to judge
whether a Kill Order should be given
there has to be a human in the loop it
cannot autonomously decide to take the
life of another human and so that made
that's a more extreme of course version
of what you're saying you're saying the
value of a human we want to retain that
otherwise just for philosophical reasons
but also we don't want AI to be our
Overlord necessarily yes
okay you agree with that okay I agree I
agree not even in the loop is a is an
architecture or a systems engineering
term used in a lot of context but you're
absolutely right that's a way to not
just
you have physical philosophically keep
humans involved but to have a Shepherd a
shepherd of these interactions and it's
until we know more Matt I think she's AI
herself I think
that's what I think say a paradox at her
and see what happens
[Laughter]
okay I'll try thanks guys for the vote
of confidence
question and just by the way for
reference I heard that fruit flies like
a banana as a kid and for years I just
thought it meant fruit flies like a
banana flies you know right yeah if you
throw a banana through the air that's
how fruit flies but um so Tegan Mercier
says I was wondering what a colony on
Space would look like what kinds of jobs
would be available and which would be of
highest importance are this are they
similar to jobs we have on Earth and
it's not asking this question but it is
implied um how high up the rank would
stand up comedian slash podcaster
um
yeah we're the comedians is there a role
for a comedians in your future universe
that's a yes I mean it seems like a
honestly quick answer but one of the
goals of democratizing access to life in
space building the artifacts of our
sci-fi space future is to build a really
richly envisioned life in space and so
what I always say to people even though
I was trained in math and science we
need everybody in the future of a life
in space we need space doctors based
lawyers based comedians entertainers and
that's part of a message I think that we
should be getting out to the public
these days which is math and science
incredibly important it is really
important to emphasize stem Fields but
it's a holistic view of the future of
the future right yeah right okay I love
that I love that
Matt was that your last question that
was the last of the patreon questions
that I had in front of me oh Michael we
never get through the whole list we
completed a testament to Ariel for being
like tight and clean answers and we just
kept this train moving Ariel you this is
a first we need an award or something
honored I don't know what that is all
right all right guys we got to call it
quits there this has been delightful and
informative and hopeful you know how
many hopeful anything's happen today
like never so so Ariel when you when you
do some when you start launching so your
your segments uh give us a call I will
we want it like but brand one star talk
or something oh my God
I love it you got it well Eric's Delight
to to see what the Arc of your life is
and will continue to be and uh maybe one
day you bring take the whole Star Talk
staff on a zero g uh plane that would be
fun we could make that happen
episode film an episode in zero g but
you have to point it away when I throw
up okay yes can't be shown throwing up
you gotta
we'll take good care of you okay
all right Ariel uh and Matt always good
to have you man always good to be here
thanks for having me all right this has
been Star Talk Cosmic queries
civilization in space Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
as always keep looking up
[Music]